[Música]
hoy no traigo ninguna presentación así
que se la van a pasar viendo eso es
porque la presentación la tengo aquí y
la tengo aquí
es importante que no
gracias
[Música]
y las tengo aquí porque es un tema que
todos los días me pregunto y me gustaría
saber si ustedes también se los
preguntan alguna vez han querido vivir
en un mundo mejor o mejor aún levanta la
mano cuántos de ustedes quieren cambiar
al mundo
otra pausa señores qué foto
gracias
pacto mi novia me dijo que me quitara la
barba terrible error muchachos no se la
quiten se las pasó de gratis pero me
gustaría utilizar puntos de ustedes y
levanten la mano quieren cambiar el
mundo
casi todos casi todas se la pueden bajar
que bueno es algo que me pregunto todos
los días porque me gustaría hacerlo y me
da mucho gusto de que ustedes también lo
quieren hacer y también veo que algunos
que no levantaron la mano y también se
vale no quererlo cambiar pero son los
más los que sí y es que me doy cuenta
que las personas que lo han cambiado
durante su vida tienen cosas que yo no
tengo y que quizás ustedes obtengan
tengo un apellido con un peso de
generaciones que yo no tengo tienen
cantidad de dinero que yo en la vida me
imagino tener empresas gigantescas
prestigio e influencia tenían seguidores
que me importa lo que ellos dijeran la
gente los iba a seguir y yo no tengo eso
todavía pero aún así me gustaría cambiar
el mundo y no quiero esperar a tener
todo eso para poderlo hacer yo pienso
que un poquito del tema y me di cuenta
que no necesito tener todo eso para
poderlo cambiar ninguno de nosotros
necesita tenerlo con hacer tres cosas
todos los días podemos cambiar al mundo
es que me di cuenta hace un par de meses
que las pequeñas cosas valen la pena y
que son las pequeñas acciones las que
tienen más peso tú eres un par de meses
que me invitaron a moderar un foro
en la preparatoria en la que yo estudié
y pues cuando llegué me di cuenta que
los chicos que iban a estar en ese foro
eran de secundaria chicos de 10 11 12 13
años todos bonitos vestidos con su
corbatita vestidito mesas chiquititas se
han regresado a su preparatoria
secundaria se van a dar cuenta que las
mesas eran una cosa de nada sillitas
están todos 13 14 chicos es un moderador
que no tenía nada especial pero para el
objetivo era tratar de mejorar la
situación del país y podemos empezaron a
hablar de que todavía en trabajar
empezaron a decir cosas acerca de
políticas públicas medio ambiente acerca
del gobierno pues muy interesantes pero
en ese momento que nos aquejaba todos
los ciudadanos en el desabasto de
gasolina nos recuerdan y les dijeron por
qué no hacemos algo más retador y por
qué no nos ponemos a trabajar acerca del
desabasto de gasolina me dijeron va si
durante las dos primeras horas empezará
a trabajar acerca de ideas para poder
solucionar la problemática y cuando me
lo presentaron dijeron podemos trabajar
sobre esta idea que estaba en bruto la
idea era una porquería no servía no
tenía innovación no de manera de
implementarla yo bueno es una propuesta
de chicos de secundaria al nivel de
chicos de secundaria pero eso no es
justificación les dije que hay veces en
las que las personas que somos más
grandes creemos que los niños por no
tener preparación por estar apenas
aprendiendo cuando tienen conocimientos
habilidades por faltar las experiencias
no son tomados en cuenta y generalmente
están ahí para aprender no para enseñar
pero yo quería lo contrario y que me
gustaría que se fuera lo utilizaban para
demostrarle al mundo que los niños de un
puente de nuevas gigantescas regresaron
a trabajar durante seis horas inicia una
propuesta al final que es impresionante
y si no hubiera ocurrido en un sistema
en el que por grupo de secundaria que
son grupos de 15 chicos ahorraban 500
mil pesos anuales en gasolina significa
menos coches menos tránsito y menos
contaminación por grupo 500 mil pesos si
lo multiplicamos por todos los grupos
del colegio ahorramos millones de pesos
este proyecto lo tiene el colegio y está
en sus manos implementarlo o no pero los
chicos lo hicieron que cambió si era yo
el mismo navegador que no tenía nada
especial y los chicos eran los mismos
que también lo que cambió es que yo
confíe en ellos que les dio una
motivación y sobre todo que yo conocía
sus capacidades y sus limitantes que
aquí también tuve 11 años pero también
conozco hasta dónde pueden llegar me
pagó la pena arriesgarse cuando me
arriesgue con ellos hicieron cosas
geniales tienen cosas impresionantes ese
es el poder de las pequeñas acciones de
las pequeñas cosas porque el de hoy en
moscú es tan importante cosas compañías
spacex no sólo hacer es la de todo en
company es una persona que quiere poder
persona en marte y no podía ojalá que
pueda porque esos sueños realidad
también es el mío es elevadísimo pero
todavía no puede si no pudiera poner una
persona en marte el es un fracasado qué
es lo que no el éxito del obtuvo hoy
porque habría de hoy no solamente él
sino tú tienes besos de amazon sacó su
propia línea aerospacial y también
richard branson con virgin galactic y el
de hoy esta es la primera vez en la
historia de la humanidad que tres
empresas privadas le apuestan a la
tecnología del espacial y les llevan
años miles de técnicos a los gobiernos
porque por qué es tan importante porque
hizo unos que lo que hizo fue inspirar a
los demás y poner el ejemplo decir si yo
puedo ustedes también pueden porque si
alguien puede todos podemos en 1950 la
meta máxima era correr una milla en
cuatro minutos con un segundo es el
límite humano durante cientos de años
ese fue el límite humano y los
científicos y los doctores pensaban que
físicamente el cuerpo no podía más y que
si intentaban vencer ese récord el
cuerpo colapsado
pero una vez un chico de medicina
fue las olimpiadas y perdió pero cuando
regresó a su país se puso de meta que
para poder trascender en la historia el
lugar romper ese récord y durante sus
estudios universitarios de medicina
entrenó física y psicológicamente para
estar ahí y cuando llegó el día de la
carrera todo estaba en su contra el
clima era terrible hacia aire y la pista
estaba mojada me gustaban con sus tenis
esos shorts y corrió y cuando vino el
tiempo del límite tres minutos 59
segundos le bajó 2 segundos el récord
mundial quien se convirtió en nuevo
campeón cuente 100 años y nadie 98 hasta
que llegó él pero no pasaron más de 50
días hasta que otra persona rompió
también el récord y otro de 50 días otra
persona rompió el récord y pasaron los
meses y pasaron los años y al día de hoy
ese récord ha sido batido miles de veces
como puede ser que durante muy poquitos
años todos batieron el récord todo 90 y
100 años nadie lo batía
porque si alguien puede todos podemos
soy quien se inspira todos podemos
inspirarnos sin alguien nos no renuncia
nadie podría renunciar y si alguien
puede todos podemos eso es lo padres
porque el mundo y la vida es un lugar
difícil la vida es como más y tiene sus
peces sus ballenas los delfines pero
también tiene sus tiburones y los erizos
y tienes que remar contracorriente un
favor que tú puedes elegir si además con
alguien más corre más tú solo o mejor
aún si tú lo ayudas a alguien más a
remar porque estás aquí no por tu propio
mérito sino por la ayuda que has
recibido
nadie puede solo tú no puedes yo no he
podido solo he recibido ayuda y es
gracias a esa ayuda vamos sólo aquí
quiero que estudiar la carrera entre
tanatorio tú mi ex novio la que me dijo
abel taco bell amor si no estudias
terminamos y estudie claro yo quería
seguir con ella fue la misma ex novedad
de este ex cabe recalcar que si
terminamos pero estuviera
sí
me dio una oportunidad laboral muy
importante y yo le quería rechazar y
ella fue la que me dijo mi amor sino más
su currículum para saber y que lo mando
llevo cuatro años al día de hoy
trabajando en la educación por culpa de
ella la primera vez que quise dar una
conferencia toqué puertas en
preparatorias y me dijeron que no todas
hasta que una me dijo siguen inténtalo a
una conferencia terrible la que había
ahí pero dos años después tras es
después aquí estoy fue hace dos años que
intenta dar mi primer la citación y
toque puertas en muchísimas
universidades no solamente de méxico de
varios países todos me dijeron o todos
los directivos me daban largas por
teléfono todos me daban mails que no
respondían hasta que una vez una
universidad en costa rica me dijo orales
y para 20 fue la costa rica con mi
equipo dimos la capacitación que luego
viendo la prospectiva que era el que
marc la capacitación vimos pero funcionó
y al día de hoy me dedico a las
capacitaciones alguien me ayudó alguna
vez
no podemos remar solos necesitamos
alguien que te ame con nosotros para
llegar hasta dónde podemos llegar
somos el resultado de la ayuda que
recibimos no del mérito único porque
nadie puede solo eso es lo más padre
porque nos ayuda a trabajar en equipo
porque la vida es difícil la vida no es
justa y está padre que no está justa
para ser un sillón de las fuerzas
especiales eeuu que también les dicen
hombres rana porque se la pasan en el
agua tienen que pasar pruebas físicas y
psicológicas muy pesadas y una de las
pruebas tiene que ver con un recorrido
nocturno nadando de varios kilómetros de
punto a punto verde la bahía y antes de
que se alienten que es en la noche hace
frío es por parejas y solamente tienes
una lamparita y tienes que aventar tela
antes de que se alienten les informan
toda la clase de tiburones que hay en la
bahía y todas las especies y bueno para
que pueda pasar también les dicen que
ningún soldado jamás ha sido asesinado
por un tiburón difícil pero que si
tuvieran la mala suerte de ir nadando en
su recorrido nocturno y tiene un tiburón
a rodear los que se queden quietos que
no hagan nada que no avancen porque el
tiburón es tiburón es el pegador y si se
siente intimidado va a morder pero
tampoco se quiera hacia atrás porque el
tiburón estimulan y si huele miedo te va
a atacar quédate quieto si tienes la
mala suerte de que el tiburón aún así
quiere
mordisco un bocadillo nocturno tiene
suficiente valor para juntarlo en tu
puño y ponerle un puñetazo y te prometo
que se va si no se apueste despedaza y
en el mar no puedes hacer nada es
tiburón
ojo muy importante una paso primero y
segundo los tipos son ustedes saben
animales muy tranquilos son las
películas las que los han satanizado
pero bueno de todas maneras si los de
dientes ahí siempre intimidante levante
la mano cuántos de ustedes han nadado
con tiburones alguna vez bien poquito yo
no que nos equipo que levanten 123
perfecto casi nadie ha nadado con
tiburones pero cuántos de ustedes no
tienen un tiburón en su vida eso es
diferente un día está más inteligente
son un tiburón que no te deja avanzar
que cuando estás en tu recorrido
nocturno quieres llegar a tu meta se
interpone en tu camino
generalmente son nuestros amigos nuestra
familia nuestros compañeros de trabajo
nuestros conocidos son esos tiburones
kim sanz porque lo hacen pero ya están
si tienes la mala suerte de estar en tu
recorrido nocturno y ver a tu tiburón de
frente quédate quieto pagas nada no
avances porque estimo un estímulo ni te
va a atacar pero tampoco te vas hacia
atrás porque el tiburón es tiburón y
trata
quédate quieto y si aún así tienes la
mala suerte de que tu tiburón te ataca
en el valor suficiente para defenderte
porque nada ni nadie tiene el derecho de
interponerse en tu camino nada ni nadie
tiene el derecho a no dejar de avanzar
en tu misión si es que tú no les das
permiso pero para eso necesitas el valor
de pararte firme y decir hasta aquí
porque la vida es difícil la vida altura
y la vida no es justa la vida nos quita
amigos nos quita a nuestra mamá a
nuestro papá a nuestros hermanos a
nuestros amigos pero también nos llega a
quitar la emoción el sentimiento ya
quitar la motivación y la esperanza y
además te deja tirado en el suelo y si
aún así tienes el valor para levantarte
y seguir adelante
créeme que tu camino lo vas a completar
pues si todo el tiempo te la pasas
lamentándote por tus circunstancias
créeme que tu vida va a ser mala va a
ser fea y no te la vas a pasar bien en
tu recorrido nocturno si tienes el valor
para continuar a pesar de que te
tropiezas vas a terminar tu recorrido
nocturno
llegar a tu misión y eso es lo más
importante porque sin dinero sin
apellido sin empresas sin influencias
sin seguidores
haciendo que tus pequeñas acciones
valgan la pena identificando tus
tiburones y levantando te encontrando un
compañero de remo para trabajar
puedes cambiar al mundo muchas gracias
[Música]